[Música]
por qué
ser o no ser
esa es la cuestión que es más noble para
el alma sufrir los dardos y flechas de
la insultante fortuna o alzarse en armas
contra un bar de agitaciones y
enfrentándose con ellas acabarlas
morir
dormir tal vez soñar sueña al que a
medrar empieza sueña el qazana y
pretende sueña el que agravia y ofende y
en conclusión todos sueñan lo que son
aunque nadie lo entiende
ya sé que sí para ser el hombre elección
tuviera ningún papel quisiera de él
mandar y regir todos quisieran mandar y
elegir
y me he liado un poco en el texto este
fijaos que la vida imita al teatro vale
leí el teatro imita a la vida entonces
puede pasar que yo ahora mismo aquí me
equivoqué y lo que estoy diciendo no
sabe cómo tendría que salir porque
porque en la vida somos personajes y
somos personas
yo me llamo marco julián y soy profesor
de interpretación soy escritor y soy
básicamente un hombre de teatro y fue
gracias al teatro que pude superar un
momento de mi vida bastante duro en el
qué
me di cuenta de que me había convertido
en un personaje secundario cuando yo
debería ser el protagonista
básicamente mi trabajo consiste en
ayudar a los demás
a crear personajes
a dotarlos de vida a darles verdad
claro el teatro se basa parece ser en
una mentira pero no es así buscamos
siempre la mayor de las verdades como es
algo que es ficticio buscamos que sea
auténtico bien pues lo que hacemos es
encontrar la verdad de esos personajes y
dotarlos de esa verdad
es lo bonito que tiene el teatro que
crea empatía porque todos mis alumnos y
alumnas sin excepción cuando crean un
personaje acaban viviendo su vida con la
de ese personaje que han creado
hay un ejemplo que os quiero poner por
ejemplo un ejercicio de clase que yo
hago en este ejercicio de clase lo que
lo que ocurre es que yo le pido a mis
alumnos que investiguen y observen y
miren a una persona cercana que esté
cerca de ellos para poder estudiar les
bien bueno pues esa persona ellos tienen
que transformarse en ella y era un día
de concreto en el que les pido que
acudan a clase siendo esa persona ya
convertida en personaje entonces viven
tres días en la vida de ese personaje
porque hay un proverbio hindú que dice
antes de juzgar a una persona camina
tres lunas con sus zapatos y eso es lo
que hacen vivir tres días en la vida de
ese personaje pues al terminar al
terminar es ese ejercicio una alumna se
me acercó y me dijo que ella había
elegido a su padre como como personaje
investigar me dijo que se había dado
cuenta de lo dura que era ella como hija
y de lo difícil que era la vida de su
padre
y entonces
cuando llegara a casa iba a hablar con
él para pedirle perdón y sobre todo
mostrarle su apoyo a partir de ese
momento a esa empatía es a la que me
refiero
entonces os hago una pregunta que yo les
hago siempre también a mis alumnos qué
diferencia hay entre personas y
personajes
vale esa persona personaje porque la je
es para mí la única diferencia que hay
entre el escenario en la vida por
ejemplo yo estoy aquí ahora y soy un
personaje estoy siendo visto por
vosotros y vosotros estéis sentados pero
no hay más diferencia porque en la vida
las personas se convierten en personajes
cuando de repente tienen que mostrar
quiénes son o tienes que decir algo
importante y son observados y saben que
lo que dice cuenta y los personajes
tienen que tener la vida real tienen que
sufrir tienen que padecer tener que
sentir exactamente lo mismo que una
persona con lo cual no hay ninguna
diferencia entre la persona y el
personaje si un personaje nace para ser
observado entonces también va a pasar
que se va a comportar de forma diferente
dependiendo de donde esté
bien
vamos a situar a ese personaje en cinco
en cinco planos por ejemplo el plano lo
laboral el plano social el plano
familiar el plano personal que es donde
nos vemos con ver a las personas más
cercanas y el plano íntimo porque a
solas también somos diferentes
voy a poner un ejemplo para entenderlo
mejor
imaginad a una persona que trabaja en
unos grandes almacenes
y esa persona viste de forma elegante
siempre tiene una sonrisa y atiende a
todos los clientes de forma muy elegante
en el pago laboral es exquisita
pero cuando termina la jornada le llaman
por teléfono sus colegas y le dicen oye
venta al bar y él en el plano social es
el alma de la fiesta va con su ropa
rockera y la lía parda pero antes de que
tiene la fiesta se va porque quiere ver
a sus hijos quiere arroparles y
desearles buenas noches porque en el
plano familiar
un padrazo y luego en el tramo personal
con su mujer la mira a los ojos y le
dice cuanto la quiere y le cuenta cómo
le ha ido el día pero luego en el plano
íntimo a solas en el espejo del baño
mirándose llora desconsoladamente porque
siente una pena que no puede explicar
así que
se ha puesto una máscara para cada una
de las situaciones que ha vivido durante
el día y es que todos nos ponemos
máscaras nos ponemos la máscara de padre
o de hijo la máscara de vecino del
trabajo que estamos ejerciendo
la máscara para ocultarlos
y el problema de las máscaras es que esa
máscara al final acaba haciéndonos creer
que somos lo que esa máscara marca es
decir acabemos comportándonos como
creemos que las personas tienen que nos
comportemos somos lo que ellos quieren
que seamos
la máscara es algo que tenemos que
controlar y saber que existe pero
también tenemos que saber que podemos
quitarnos la
esto es muy fácil de entender si nos
vamos a instagram por ejemplo cuando
vamos a instagram al final del día como
personajes que somos ponemos la foto que
creemos que nuestro público quiere ver
de nosotros nos debemos a nuestro
público como personajes y queremos
continuar una historia así que le damos
al público esa foto que creemos que
quieren ver pero no la que nos
representa de verdad
lorca en comedia sin título sobre la
cavada decía que vamos al teatro a ver
lo que pasa y no a ver lo que nos pasa
y porque os cuento todo esto y os hablo
de máscaras y al principio hablaba de
hamlet o hablaba de la vida del sueño o
se hablaba del gran teatro del mundo
y notaba mis nervios y veía como no era
capaz de seguir con el texto porque la
persona y el personaje se confunden aquí
en este escenario donde siendo personaje
también soy persona porque os hablo de
todo esto porque yo durante una época de
mi vida llevé una máscara que no quería
llevar
una máscara que ni siquiera sabía que
llevaba
y era la máscara neutra
él
para mí el peor problema de la depresión
fue el miedo
fue el miedo a no saber quién yo era era
un miedo que se colaba por la puerta
subía por las piernas se instalaba en mí
sin que yo pudiera evitarlo
el miedo a no saber de verdad mi
identidad
así que una vez escuché a un psicólogo
decir que los pacientes de depresión
sienten que no pueden sentir piensan que
no hay futuro
y no sienten nada alrededor de ellos
y ahí estaba yo sin futuro
y poder sentir y con una máscara neutra
pero la máscara neutra del teatro es muy
interesante porque te la pones para que
tu rostro no exprese nada y hacer todo
con tu cuerpo con con tus gestos y es
mágica porque el que te ve cuando te
observa a actuar
cree que la máscara mágicamente cambia
de expresión pero tú no expresas nada no
sientes nada
una máscara neutra
así que ahí estaba yo con mis alumnos
enseñándoles a vivir vidas ajenas como
propias
cuando yo mismo no era capaz de
controlar la mía
y entonces tuve una revelación
estaba haciendo un personaje
insignificante en una vida en la que
debería ser el protagonista el máximo
protagonista
así que si la vida es como una obra de
teatro
y las personas son como personajes
porque no aplicar todas las herramientas
que yo había usado en mis clases para
volver a tomar esas riendas de mi vida
para convertirme en protagonista de esta
historia la mía
y entonces empecé por una parte que fue
situar mi vida en un esto en una línea
temporal es lo que en dramaturgia
moderna llamamos el paradigma de shift
field que consiste en lo siguiente hay
tres actos el acto uno la introducción
el acto dos el desarrollo y el acto tres
el desenlace la conclusión
como en el colegio siempre nos han
enseñado esto bien la primera escena ya
la teníamos es el nacimiento todos los
que estamos aquí hemos nacido en el
primer momento de nuestra vida si no
sería un poco extraño y la última
también la tenemos y no estoy quiere
hacer spoiler pero todos vamos a morir
esa escena va a suceder y no tampoco me
quiero poner ahora triste en lo que
cuento ni ser dramático pero es que la
muerte es inexorable así que teníamos la
primera escena y la última escena ahora
hay que llenar ese paradigma de historia
en el primer acto podemos hablar de el
momento del que nos necesitan de ese
momento en el que empezamos a entender
la vida empezamos a ver de qué va el
mundo y empezamos a plantearnos hacia
adelante en el desarrollo es más
complejo porque empezamos a cumplir
objetivos conocemos gente las relaciones
son más profundas y vamos avanzando
avanzando hasta llegar a la conclusión
donde por fin podemos y mirar hacia
atrás y ver lo que hemos logrado y
cerrar las historias abiertas
todo esto si nuestra vida es más o menos
estándar porque puede ocurrir por
desgracia el tercer acto se cuele en
cualquier momento del paradigma y no se
interrumpa en la vida tal y como la
conocemos
y entonces lo que hice fue situar en ese
paradigma los momentos más relevantes de
mi vida como si fueran escenas de una
obra de teatro
y llegué a otro elemento del término que
es y field
usa que llama el punto medio
el punto medio es ese momento en la
historia en el que todo cambia es un
punto de inflexión es ese momento en el
que de repente nos damos cuenta de que
va la historia
pues se llama punto medio porque ocurre
en el medio claro porque es una historia
de ficción sabemos el tiempo real de lo
que va a durar la vida la historia pero
en la vida no lo sabemos en la vida lo
que pasa es que puede ocurrir en
cualquier momento del final así que para
mí el punto medio era un punto de
inflexión un punto de revelación
el punto en el que me daba cuenta de
cómo controlar todas las cosas o al
menos de que quería hacerlo ahora muchos
de vosotros incluso estaréis preguntando
si vuestro punto medio ha sucedido ya el
mío curiosamente ocurrió a los 40 años
así que
si mi vida más o menos va a ser estándar
el punto medio coincide exactamente con
eso bien que tenía la línea y la línea
ya de la historia ahora faltaba darle a
mi personaje las herramientas que le
damos a los personajes cuando trabajamos
en clase un personaje tiene lo que
llamamos el súper objetivo
qué es el superobjetivo el superobjetivo
es lo que el personaje quiere conseguir
durante toda la historia es su máximo su
máximo logro y luego tiene pequeños
objetivos que van sumando para poder
conseguirlo en mi caso era volver a ser
protagonista de mi historia y
convertirme en la persona que yo quería
realmente ser
pero para eso tenía que mirar hacia
atrás aprender de los hechos y mirar
desde adelante y no era fácil ir hacia
adelante porque nos vamos a encontrar lo
que son los conflictos un conflicto es
un término que viene a definir la
oposición al objetivo tu te lanzas hacia
algo pero el conflicto lo impide y hay
dos conflictos el externo el que te da
la historia la vida vivir en sí mismo ya
es un conflicto constante y luego está
el interno que va más contigo mismo el
conflicto interno es el que va con la
ética con la moral de la persona con
como tú eres es lo que comúnmente
podemos llamar
pepitogrillo así que tenía los
conflictos tenía los objetivos tenían
súper objetivo pero al protagonista le
faltaba algo porque en toda historia hay
un personaje principal que también es
muy relevante que es el antagonista el
que se opone al el protagonista el que
le impide avanzar el que le propone los
conflictos
y ese antagonista lo busqué en el
momento de mi vida busqué por todos
lados quién podía ser el antagonista a
quien estaba haciendo algo para que yo
no avanzara
y entonces me di cuenta
de que el antagonista era yo mismo de
que yo me estaba poniendo la zancadilla
al de que era yo que me impedía
conseguir los objetivos de que era yo
quién potenciaba esos conflictos así que
para vencer a es antagonista como ocurre
en las historias tuve que entenderle
observarla analizarlo e incluso
abrazarle
y así poder liberarme de él y avanzar
hacia adelante porque lo importante de
los objetivos es que te dan motivación
para seguir avanzando y avanzando e ir
hacia tu destino
e ir hacia adelante y eso
el revelador pero también es muy duro
porque cargar con todos tus errores
aceptarlos abrazarlos y avanzar
siempre es muy duro siempre muy difícil
pero si lo aceptas el camino es mucho
mejor es mucho más favorable
y eso
eso no quiere decir
que no podamos dudar como hamlet de si
somos o no somos o de quejarnos cuando
se repartan los papeles en el gran
teatro del mundo porque hay que definir
a la persona hay que dotarla de
herramientas para convertirlo en este
protagonista y hay que luchar
para que cada escena que te queda por
vivir hasta llegar a la conclusión final
merezca la pena para que tú seas mejor
cada día
para evitar esa máscara neutra
y sobre todo
hay que confiar confiar porque como
decía chaplin
el tiempo
es el mejor de los autores
siempre escribe el mejor de los finales
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]